hört man diesen Müllwagen
[Musik]
hallo ihr Lieben wir machen heute eine
white chocolate Tat mit Kokos und das
ganze in den no back Variante und zwar
ohne eine spezielle tatform also es wird
ein sehr einfaches schnelles und
unglaublich leckeres Rezept ich mache
jetzt zuallererst mal einen Keksboden
und ihr wisst ja bei meinen Videos
schreibe ich euch die ganz genauen
Mengenangaben immer unten in die
genau
so die Kekse werden jetzt schön fein
gemahlen Butter habe ich gerade schon in
der Mikrowelle zerlassen nimmt da immer
lieber die geringe Wattzahl also lieber
360 Watt oder sowas bevor die Butter
euch platzt und die ganze Mikrowelle
eingesaut ist und sobald ihr das dann
gemixt habt könnt ihr die Butter
hinzugeben und alles gut vermengen
[Musik]
so der Keksboden ist soweit jetzt habe
ich hier einen Tortenring damit könnt
ihr nämlich auch ganz einfach eine
schöne Tarte zubereiten ihr habt da halt
nur nicht diese Wellen außenrum aber ich
finde die braucht es auch gar nicht so
ich stelle meinen Tortenring ein auf 22
cm zack
ich packe meinen Koffer
Tonlage ne so 22 cm braucht ihr dann
braucht den Backpapier beachtet bitte
nicht die vielen Logos das ist das aus
der Gastro aus dem Kaffee aber ich habe
kein normales Backpapier mehr zu Hause
gehabt so und jetzt schon
mal ein einfach damit es nicht nervt und
einfach schön eng anliegend ist braucht
ihr eigentlich nicht weil es ist ja
nichts was ausläuft ihr macht einfach
nur Keksboden rein aber das hier könnt
ihr jetzt euch auch noch mal merken für
flüssigere Teige weil mit dem Torten
könnt ihr natürlich auch Backen der ist
hitzebeständig auch die Klemmung hier
vorne und dann müsstet ihr quasi immer
wieder dass wir von außen nach innen
knicken so ist ja einmal im Kreis
angekommen seid und dann seid ihr
eigentlich schon fertig so um das
gleiche transportieren habe ich jetzt
hier noch ein cakeboard unten drunter
und jetzt füllt ihr den kompletten
Keksboden einmal ein und dann müssen wir
einen ja so wie hoch ist das gut dass
ich diese Zentimeter Angaben innen habe
das ich sage ja das ist ein richtiger
Game change
ich persönlich aufgefallen ich habe so
Geräusche gehört aber ich dachte zu
nerven du bist schon überleben
also ich würde sagen macht den Rand so 3
cm hoch also erstmal verteile ich das
hier gleichmäßig später nehme ich mir
auch noch ein Glasboden um das schön
flach anzudrücken und dann könnt ihr das
eigentlich das funktioniert immer am
besten mit den sauberen Händen
nee die Hände wäscht man sich nicht
eigentlich hier so ein Rand andrücken
und den dann noch mal begradigen wir
füllen ja gleich noch mal so eine
richtig leckere Kokos Pudding Füllung
ein und die muss nicht komplett
abschließen mit dem Rand also die ragt
auch noch so ein bisschen drüber daher
braucht es nicht so genau nee macht
einfach nach Gefühl
so der Boden ist soweit fertig ihr könnt
jetzt entweder bis zur
Weiterverarbeitung in den Kühlschrank
stellen dann sitzt alles noch mal schön
oder einfach an die Seite geben weil das
ganze wirklich sowieso noch gekühlt
übrigens findet Ihr nicht nur alle ganz
genauen Mengenangaben in der Infobox
sondern auch mein Equipment wie zum
Beispiel den Tortenring etc und alles
was ihr dann noch so benötigen könntet
und wir haben sogar auf der Webseite
immer oben auf der Leiste unseren
aktuellen Rabattcode das heißt den könnt
ihr dann auch noch nutzen und sogar was
sparen so ich mache jetzt hier die
kokosfüllung mit weißer Schokolade dafür
habe ich die weiße die weiße zahnkultur
nein
dafür habe ich die weiße Kuvertüre fein
gehackt ihr könntet jetzt auch einfach
Tafel Schokolade nehmen also es muss
jetzt nicht unbedingt Kuvertüre sein ich
nehme immer das was ich gerade da habe
so dann bin ich hier am Herd habe jetzt
meine Pfanne genommen eigentlich würde
ich jetzt ohne Kamera mein Topf nehmen
aber in der Pfanne habe ich das Gefühl
seht ihr einfach besser bzw
einfach nur rein tun den Herd noch nicht
einschalten weil die Speisestärke muss
ich jetzt erstmal mit der Milch
verbinden da könnt ihr aber jetzt gleich
auch schon direkt Vanilleextrakt mit
dazugeben einfach für den guten
Geschmack
ach liebe das so und da einfach noch mal
mit dem Schneebesen reingehen alles
Klümpchen frei verrühren und dann könnt
ihr den Herd einschalten und das ganze
Jahr quasi aufkochen lassen immer rühren
damit da nichts anbrennen wobei ich
sagen muss weil mein Fondant sowieso die
was an aber dann könnt ihr anschließend
auch schon Kokosraspeln mit dazu geben
wenn ihr merkt das dick zu allmählich
ein
[Musik]
nachdem das Ganze einmal aufkocht liegt
das auch schon ein und ihr könnt den
Herd ausschalten und die weiße Kuvertüre
einfach in der Resthitze schmelzen
lassen das Ganze lasse ich dann 5
Minuten ausdampfen und gebe dann
Mascarpone dazu ihr merkt auch dass sich
alles dann so von beige auf ich würde
sagen weiß aber auf heller verfärbt
durch die Mascarpone und die locker hat
das Ganze auch noch mal ein bisschen auf
gerade auch im Anschnitt so und jetzt
gebe ich einfach nur noch die
kokosfüllung quasi in den Tortenring und
dann einmal glatt verstreichen und am
besten kühlt ihr das jetzt so ca 4
Stunden ihr könnt solche Geschichten
aber auch immer am Vorabend schon
vorbereiten und dann halt über Nacht
kühlen und dann fehlt ja eigentlich nur
noch gleich unsere weiße
Schokoladenglasur und die Deko
[Musik]
nach der Kühlzeit machen wir die schöne
Glasur davon nehmen wir uns einfach nur
weiße Schokolade oder weiße Kuvertüre
und Sahne ich empfehle euch aber auf
jeden Fall ein Schmelztopf zu benutzen
weil gerade bei weißer Schokolade ist es
so dass sie sehr schnell klumpt und ihr
dann eben nicht so eine schöne feine
Glasur habt also gerne über einem
Wasserbad einfach Wasser erhitzen
Schmelztopf oben drauf geben und dann
langsam langsam das Schmerzen lassen so
das gebe ich jetzt hier einmal auf die
kalte Oberfläche und dann werde ich das
wahrscheinlich schwenkend hin und her
schieben ihr könnt es aber auch mit
einem mit einer Winkel Palette einfach
machen und sobald das dann noch mal
abgekühlt ist dann gebe ich noch mal für
10 Minuten in den Kühlschrank kommt die
Deko und da werde ich dann
wahrscheinlich das nehme ich denn da ach
weißt du was lass mich selber
überraschen
[Musik]
die weiße Glasur ist jetzt extra noch
cremig also wenn ihr schneidet ist sie
nicht so knackig das wollte ich nämlich
nicht und jetzt müssen wir aber zuerst
mal den Tortenring lösen die jetzt hier
mein Backform Löser und gerade weil wir
jetzt auch am Rand noch mal mit diesem
Keksboden hochgegangen sind ist es ganz
wichtig dass ihr das wirklich ganz
vorsichtig erstmal löst und dann den
Ring entfernt weil wenn ihr jetzt den
Ring einfach abnimmt dann reißt euch das
quasi einfach komplett durch und dann
war die ganze Mühe umsonst einmal eine
schöne Runde man spürt auch richtig wie
dieser Boden so abgeht und sich vom
Tortenring löst
ich liebe man diesen Moment wenn man den
Tortenring hochzieht das war mein Magic
Moment
[Musik]
doch genau so wollte ich ihn haben so
war ja auch bei mir in meinem Rezept
Test dass man einfach echt noch so viel
vom Keksboden sieht aber das eben
richtig toll abschließt mit dem weißen
ich finde es auch richtig hübsch das
werde ich das einmal transferieren auf
mein Port und dann schneide ich das in
Stückchen denke mal da kann man locker
12 Stücke rausschneiden
so mit dem cakeboard könnt ihr jetzt
hier natürlich auch ganz easy peasy
unten drunter viele sagen ja man geht
das dann so einfach oder klebt das dann
fest nee guck mal das geht so einfach
zack einmal runter nehmen Backpapier weg
und dann hier einfach drauf schieben
so ich dekoriere jetzt übrigens noch mit
Kokosraspeln ich überlege noch Kokos
Chips mit dazu zu nehmen aber hier noch
dieses beige muss mal gucken wie es
aussieht und was ich auf jeden Fall dazu
nehme einfach weil ich finde es passt
und was auch farblich gut aussieht
gefriergetrocknete Erdbeeren das ist ja
leider keine Saison sonst hätte ich auch
frische Erdbeeren genommen aber
gefriergetrocknete Erdbeeren sind
einfach erntefrische Erdbeeren die
gefriergetrocknet werden das heißt es
wird das ganze Wasser entzogen und was
bleibt sind richtig knackige in unserem
Fall jetzt halbierte Erdbeeren die
schmecken so süß und so richtig richtig
lecker im Auto snicke ich immer so eine
ganze Packung ganz alleine weg aber wie
gesagt darum soll es jetzt nicht gehen
wir machen das jetzt einfach als Deko
noch mal auf unsere Torte und vorher
teile ich das aber ja schauen wir mal
durch 12 oder 14
[Musik]
boah junge Mädel was machst du mit mir
was machst du mir so dann lass uns mal
das Gute Stückchen probieren ich finde
es auch richtig schön serviert ne weiß
aber ja
mega schön so tut mir leid ich muss nur
ein ein Foto machen bitte natürlich
bei der Glasur ich habe gesagt die ist
extra schön weich und wenn ihr die
Stücke schon anschneidet bei dir sieht
man es richtig dann läuft die Glasur mit
der Zeit echt noch mal so runter an der
Seite
[Musik]
so frisch das schmeckt so frisch
mega gut und das gute ist ja kein
zusätzlichen Zucker hier im in der
Füllung weil wir haben schon die Süße
aus der Schokolade wir haben die
Kokosraspeln
also ich wusste ja dass der gut schmeckt
aber wenn man ihn dann noch mal richtig
gekühlt ist
die Kokosraspeln in dieser Creme die
geben so diesen kleinen Crunch ich mag
das voll ja und Crunch hast du auch noch
mal im Boden ich finde das
bodenfüllung gussverhältnis
12 und 10
Leute ich mache das auf jeden Fall öfter
ich sage euch wirklich gegessen
also wer den nicht nachmacht hat selber
schuld weil er was verpasst hat also
dann würde ich mal behaupten bis zum
nächsten Mal auf die Kinder
seid weil ich muss ehrlich sagen ich
will du weißt ich bin white verrückt ne
Sneaker muss ich sofort probieren alles
mögliche in white da bin ich immer voll
mit dabei vielleicht kommt der bald
etwas
Spoiler
ich würde mal sagen bis zum nächsten mal
ganz kurz
raus und dann weißt Du so drauf
gerade
also Leute viel Spaß Leute nachmachen
[Musik]